How's it going everyone and welcome back
to another video. This is part three in
our weekly profile series and this video
is over consolidation reversal. So if
you haven't already seen the video on
classic expansion and midweek reversal,
go ahead and check that out first. But
that is when we get neither of those
situations first. So here if we were
looking for a bearish move, we'd be
checking to see do we have a classic
expansion week and you can see we don't
get any expansion through Wednesday. You
can see we've consolidated, so there's
no way to have a midweek reversal. And
that is when we come to a consolidation
reversal. A consolidation reversal is
when we have a consolidation Monday,
Tuesday and Wednesday and then we're
looking for a manipulation of that range
to then trade the other way. So you can
see Thursday takes out Monday's high and
then we have an expansion lower on
Thursday and Friday. In the bullish
scenario, we take out Monday's low
forming the low of the week and then we
can trade higher following that. So what
do we notice here is on a consolidation
reversal, generally it looks like a
candle two closure on Thursday, which
you can trade it as a small wick or you
can just wait for Friday, but we are
taking out our previous day's high
closing back below it and we're also
taking out our Monday's high and closing
back below it. This allows us to
anticipate that Friday can continue
lower if what? If we have a change in
the state of delivery inside this candle
two or inside Thursday's range. Now the
same thing with the bullish scenario. We
take out Monday's low as well as our
previous day's low and close back above
that. We can look to trade that higher
on the following day given that we have
a change in the state of delivery inside
that candle two or on Thursday. And here
you can see we want to look to trade
this towards what? A higher time frame
key level or until we hit our average
daily range. So letting that play out,
you can see this is what our weekly
candle will look like and this is what
our daily candle will look like after it
expands. So let's get into TradingView
and go over a few examples. So here we
are in our first example and what do we
have here? We have a fair value gap and
then we have price closing through the
series of up close candles into that
fair value gap. So we can look for this
to continue to expand lower. Let's see
what Monday does. Does Monday respect
this area? It does. So if we're going to
get an expansion lower, we'd want to see
that expand on Tuesday lower. But what
do we get? We get a consolidation.
So now this is nothing more than what? A
consolidation range. So let's go ahead
and mark that up. You can see we have a
consolidation range. Monday, Tuesday and
Wednesday have all consolidated. So what
do we want to see? We want to see what
happens on Thursday here.
Here on Thursday you can see we take out
the consolidation low. So Monday,
Tuesday and Wednesday low as well as the
swing low. We close back inside the
previous candle's range. So that is
forming a candle two closure here. And
what do we have? We have all these
failure swings above. We could look for
Friday to expand higher if we have what?
An hourly change in the state of
delivery. So coming down here to the
hourly time frame, you can see we find
the low. We find the series of candles
that made that low. My indicator marks
out that change in the state of delivery
and so we could be looking for a
continuation higher in Friday because we
have a consolidation reversal. Price
consolidates Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
then Thursday forms a reversal. So a
consolidation reversal, Friday is our
continuation day in which we can look
for it to trade into the previous highs
as well as that range high. So here you
can see my indicator marks out the T
spot, the area where I want to see price
react from on this intraday time frame.
Let's see how that works.
And there you go. You can see we have
that expansion on Friday. So let's go
back out to the daily chart. So back out
here on the daily chart, what do we
have? We have Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday
all forming a consolidation. Thursday
forms that reversal, so we have a
consolidation reversal and Friday is the
day that we want to look to trade as
that is the day that is set up for
expansion. Let's get into another
example.
Here we are in our next example and what
do we notice about this previous week?
We have expanded into an objective. So
this means we can get a new phase of
price right here. We could get a
retracement into a gap to continue
higher, a consolidation or a reversal.
So let's see what happens on these next
days.
Right here we're getting a little bit of
a consolidation
and what do we notice on Wednesday? This
is more of a consolidation or a
retracement. Now I want to ask myself if
I'm still bullish looking out of this
gap here, could I say that Wednesday has
formed the low? No, I would not trust
myself to say that Wednesday has formed
a low because this is a bearish
expansion candle. We need to let another
day play out. Now what do we notice
here? We have Thursday forming a
reversal or a candle two closure and
it's an ideal candle two closure as it
also forms a protected swing. So now
what do we have? We have a consolidation
through Wednesday. Thursday forms a
reversal. What can we look for on Friday
here? For Friday to expand because we
have a consolidation reversal profile.
So what do we need to check next? So now
down here on the hourly time frame, what
do we need to confirm? We need to
confirm that we have that change in the
state of delivery. So finding the low in
Thursday, have we closed through the
series of down close candles? We have
right here. So if you're taking a look,
we have a new continuation that has also
formed. We can look for Friday to expand
here.
And you can see Friday does get that
expansion higher off of Thursday's
reversal. So just to review, Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday forming
consolidation.
Thursday forms a reversal. Could you
trade this reversal day? Sure, but I
prefer to wait for the continuation day
on the following day. So you can see
here on Friday we get a nice large range
expansion. So going back out to the
daily chart, you can see Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday form a consolidation
or a small opposing run. Thursday
reversal, Friday continuation. So this
is an example of a consolidation
reversal weekly profile.
So here we are in another example and
what do we notice? You can see we have
taken out this high on the left here and
we have expanded into that. So we can be
looking for a new phase of price here.
We can either see a reversal to go back
across the range, a retracement into
this gap to then go higher or some sort
of consolidation or the mix of the two.
So let's see what happens here.
What do we get on Monday? A small range.
Tuesday?
No direction, right? This is a doji
candle taking out both sides of the
range. That's not giving us any
information.
Wednesday also a consolidation. Let's
see what Thursday does.
And what do we notice about Thursday
here? We reach into this fair value gap
and not only that, but we have a candle
two closure. So if we're going to be
looking for expansion now after these
candles have played out, what do we view
this as? A consolidation or a
retracement, right? A large range to a
small range. We can be looking for a
continuation.
Where would we be looking for this
continuation to go to? Well, into the
other side of the range or this range
high.
Now before we get ahead of ourselves,
what do we need to look for? Go down to
the hourly chart and we need to make
sure that we have what? An hourly change
in the state of delivery. So zooming in
here, you can see we find the series of
candles that made this low. Have we
closed over it? Yes. So we could be
looking for a continuation here on
Friday. Now you can see the little green
box. That's where I'm looking for price
to respect, right? And why is that?
Well, we have a new continuation with
this closure through. So we don't want
to see price do what? Take out this low.
All right, so we want to see price form
its lower wick in this area to then
trade higher.
Here you can see we go a little bit
lower.
We have an SMT on the low, but then we
expand through the other side of the
range. So you can see this weekly
candle, it spent Monday, Tuesday,
Wednesday and Thursday forming the wick
of this candle. But after Thursday once
the wick has formed, we get Friday
having that large expansion. So once
again, Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday either
a retracement or a consolidation, a
small opposing run. Thursday forms a
reversal and then Friday is that
continuation.
Now with that, I hope you enjoyed the
video and you now understand what a
consolidation reversal weekly profile
is. If you did, please consider liking
and subscribing and I'll see you guys in
the next one. Have a good one.